hey quick announcement the channel now
has official merge head on to
crowdmate.com using the link in the
description or through the pin to
comment okay on with the video
[Music]
rome nicknamed the eternal city it's
well known for its museums from the
frescoed paintings of the vatican to the
abandoned ruins of the roman forum but
there's one museum i bet you haven't
heard of a museum with a very disturbing
collection
attached to a small church there's a
quiet room that houses ghostly artifacts
with messages from beyond the grave
from dark handprints seared onto wood to
phantom markings etched in prayer books
the museum's haunting exhibits are
dedicated to the souls of the dead and
record their eerie communications with
the living
it has to be one of the most disturbing
museums around but why does it exist
what's it for and how do we know that
any of these objects are indeed genuine
welcome to strange christian art this
episode the museum of lost souls
the story of how this museum came to be
is just as dark as its contents
the little museum of purgatory as it's
known can be found in the church of the
sacred heart of suffrage it's a very
unusual church the only one in rome
built in a gothic style it looks out of
place amongst the baroque domes and
renaissance arches the building you see
today is not the first church on this
site in fact the original had burnt down
in a fire it was the evening of the 15th
of september 1897 when smoke was seen
rising from the church's roof by that
point it was too late the old rafters
and beams were already ablaze
all parishioners and priests could do
was look unhelplessly as their place of
worship was consumed by fire one of the
onlookers father victor jouer is said to
have seen something very strange within
the flames looking back at him was the
face of a man he had an anguished
expression and looked to be in pain
surveying the damage the next day the
same face had been burned onto a wall a
deeply religious man the priest took
this as a sign
this face he believed was the soul of a
man trapped in purgatory a middle realm
between heaven and hell
as the church began reconstruction he
set out to travel around europe looking
for more evidence of lost souls
for those unfamiliar with the idea
purgatory is the place for those who are
not quite good enough for heaven but
also not quite evil enough for hell
purgatory is the destiny for the
mediocre for those who fell slightly
short of heaven's demanding entry
requirements to escape purgatory souls
have to purge themselves of all
remaining sin often by completing
difficult trials or having loved ones
praying on their behalf
in doing so they will be allowed to
proceed and finally enter heaven the
idea of purgatory is not universally
accepted amongst christians especially
as it's not really mentioned in the
bible the concept seems to date to the
middle ages to a legend about an 11th
century abbot called odilo of clooney in
one version of the story he'd been
shipwrecked on a mysterious island there
he met a hermit who told him about a
chasm where lost souls were able to
escape the clutches of hell when the
abbott returned home he established a
festival called all souls day to honor
the dead and to offer them prayers
another writer who wrote a lot about
purgatory was the medieval poet dante
alighieri in his sequel to inferno he
envisioned purgatory as a giant mountain
in the southern hemisphere the mountain
was made up of layers of terraces each
representing one of the seven deadly
sins
in the poem dante meets with souls on
their way to heaven and describes the
difficult trials they must face in order
to proceed
for example on the first terrace pride
souls must carry heavy boulders past
statues of saints doing so would teach
them humility
on terrace 3 wrath souls must walk
through a blanket of thick acrid smoke
symbolizing how anger can blind good
judgment
on the final terrace lust souls must
pass through an intense wall of flame to
burn away all remaining sin
finally cleansing them before they enter
heaven
it's not quite the horror of dante's
inferno
but purgatory is not quite a paradise
either
in the late middle ages the doctrine of
purgatory became very popular there were
even tickets known as indulgences where
you could buy forgiveness of sin
speeding up the journey of a deceased
relative as they made their way up the
mountain but in later centuries
purgatory fell out of favor especially
in branches of christianity like
protestantism for catholics however it
still remains a core belief
[Music]
as father jouer returned from his
travels in europe he brought with him
items that supposedly proved the
existence of purgatory he had gathered a
dozen or so of these objects each with a
unique story
placing them in a small annex of the
newly constructed church he opened his
morbid collection to the public
this item exhibit 7c is a dark handprint
that has been seared onto a wooden board
in the upper corner there's a small
cross the story goes that this is the
ghostly hand of one p panzini who on the
1st of november 1731 returned as a
spirit to make this ghoulish imprint
it was followed by two more handprints
one staining a piece of parchment and
the other on a nun's robe
the ghost of your handprints came with a
plea
pray for my soul and end my suffering in
purgatory many of the other exhibits are
books with phantom markings such as
exhibit nine a german prayer book with
five finger holes burnt in the pages the
book belonged to giorgio schips who on
the 21st of december 1838 saw a set of
spectral fingerprints char the paper in
front of him apparently it was his
brother giuseppe who had died a few
months prior he asked his brother for
forgiveness to save his soul that was
trapped between heaven and hell
one of my favorites is this object
exhibit three it's a nightcap that
belonged to a man called luigi he too
was visited by a strange apparition it
turned out to be the specter of his wife
luisa whose ghostly apparition created a
small hole in the cat
another disturbing story but i think
there's a more mundane explanation to
this one if you ask me this looks more
like the work of moths who are known to
chew through clothing making these
rather distinctive round holes just a
theory
the room is full of unique exhibits like
these a book that has three ghostly
finger marks at the base
stained clothing of unknown origin and
even a haunted banknote
each one has a legend to go with it all
following a rather similar format vision
of a deceased relative a strange mark
appears
and a request for a prayer on their
behalf
as a collection this small museum
attempts to prove the existence of
purgatory showcasing the ways in which
lost souls have attempted to communicate
with the living since father zhuai's
death in 1912 nothing new has been added
unfortunately that charred face that
inspired the museum is nowhere to be
seen
as with any strange supernatural
phenomenon there's always a question of
whether any of these items are really
genuine
whether or not you believe in an
afterlife is up to you but could these
objects be fakes
for example let's look at that handprint
again it doesn't look very natural the
proportions are a bit off what's more
handprints are not completely flat like
this and instead are made up of contours
and ridges it's likely that this
handprint was simply drawn on perhaps
using a hot iron after all you can even
see a faint outline etched into the wood
i remain skeptical about some of these
exhibits but there are others that are a
little harder to explain
like the prayer book with those finger
holes how do you create those marks
without burning the rest of the paper
and indeed some of the other hand prints
like this one seem to look a bit more
natural i'm sure there are plenty of
rational explanations here but when it's
hard to figure out paranormal activity
is always a tempting option
despite these exhibits claiming to prove
the existence of purgatory the catholic
church takes a dim view to these kinds
of objects especially as they are so
easy to forge of course there are plenty
of strange relics out there but usually
they're connected to some sort of saint
often their physical remains these items
however are not technically holy relics
as they are traces of ordinary people
despite the supernatural stories about
their origin for now little is known
about them i suspect it will always be
that way
[Music]
the museum of lost songs is not for the
faint of heart where most museums
showcase things from this world our
museum is focused on what comes after
real or not these gruesome exhibits
still have an eerie feel to them there's
something unsettling about the idea of
the dead reaching back out into the
world of the living if you're ever
visiting rome i would recommend giving
the site a visit just look out for the
out of place church along the tiber
river
this little museum with its ominous
handprints and books with scars is a
mystery and a disturbing glimpse of what
might await us in the afterlife
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i had a great
time making this and i hope you enjoyed
it as well
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way oh and
do check out the channel's merch over at
crowdmade we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies links are in description down
below
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]